the country of yoga
the country of Ganzi and non-violence
[Music]
the country where you travel to grow
spiritually is the very same country
where the far-right wing has won the
elections again if you think ultra
nationalism is a Western thing you
should better think again but even by
the end of this video Donald Trump is
going to look like a liberal hippie to
you
[Applause]
[Music]
India is the world's biggest democracy
you heard that right in this past
election more than 600 million people
cast their votes this is twice as much
as the entire population of the United
States nevertheless I bet you couldn't
even name their Prime Minister
oh yes it doesn't matter if India is the
second most populated country on the
planet or the world's largest democracy
the media just couldn't care less about
this country and this is why here a
visual politic we're obliged to tell you
about this man that you see on the
screen right now Narendra Modi this man
has just been reelected as the Indian
Prime Minister many of you might think
that looking this peaceful being
vegetarian and practicing yoga that Modi
would be a spiritual politician who
loves peace and human rights right well
actually no the opposite is true
next in render Modi Donald Trump looks
like bono from u2
[Music]
have you ever heard about India's sacred
cows well yes they are real and believe
me when I say that this is much more
than just a funny thing from Hinduism
the cow bells is a group of Indian
states where religion plays a major role
in society within these regions we have
the calve Atlantis theoretically the cow
vigilantes role is to protect these
animals but in many cases they formed
into violent tribes that attack
minorities mainly Muslims according to a
Human Rights Watch report in the last
five years they have killed more than 44
people just because they were eating
beef in other words you can find
fanatics in any religion including
Hinduism
[Music]
but if India is the world's largest
democracy their elections are also the
world's longest in most democratic
countries voting lasts for one or two
days in India it takes seven weeks why
because every state holds elections on
different days and remember we're
talking about 900 million possible
voters here along with long elections
the campaign has also been a hell of a
show from the tension with Pakistan to a
Bollywood movie yes you had that right
if spots weren't enough Narendra Modi
made his own Bollywood biopic Prime
Minister Narendra Modi movie review an
unabashed hagiography with such a huge
electoral campaign Modi has been
reelected in a landslide victory
disappears party has 65 percent of the
seats in the parliament this is similar
to the majority that Putin in Russia has
or Orman has in Hungary and the
opposition parties in India are too
small to effectively block his policies
so today's question is why is India
decided to give even more support to the
far-right can we really say that this
country is radicalizing and what kind of
consequences will this have for the rest
of the world well today we're going to
answer all of these questions but before
we do let's take a look back at the
history
[Music]
bori would mahatma ghandi is more than
the founding father of modern day India
he is a universal icon his goal was that
once India became independent both
Hindus and Muslims could coexist
peacefully although India is a Hindu
majority country they also have a Muslim
minority well it's not even fair to say
that it's a minority really because
we're talking about more than 200
million people who believe in Muhammad's
teachings that said both Gandhi and Modi
were born in the same state and this is
where the similarities between these two
and Modi was born into a humble family
and since he was a child he was
fascinated by politics so where did he
go he went to the association of
national volunteers also known as the
Shang family this is a radical Hindu
organization with a clear target in mind
Muslims are the enemy to give you a
better understanding the man who shot
Gandhi was affiliated with this
organization and yes he killed Gandhi
because Gandhi had the goal of making
Hindus and Muslims coexist peacefully so
the sharing family formed the basis of
Narendra Modi's political party to
Bharatiya Janata Party also known as the
BJP as you can imagine the ideology of
this party is not exactly centrist
nevertheless soon became one of the
biggest political groups in all of India
here is where Modi kick-started his
political career in 2001 he became the
chief minister of the state of Gujarat
and this is how his legend started
basically Modi combines the BJP is
radical narrative with a taste for
pragmatic economics on the radical side
he even lost the visa to travel to
America of the European Union the reason
was that he allowed Hindu radicals to
basically oppress Muslims
[Music]
in 2002 Hindu radicals killed more than
a thousand Muslims Modi's administration
was accused of handing the radicals list
all the properties owned by Muslims on
the other hand Modi had his bright side
in economics he privatized several state
owned enterprises he created industrial
parks and removed a lot of red tape
which is a persistent problem across all
of India in very few years Gujarat was
growing at a 10 percent rate year after
year everybody saw Modi as a model for
the rest of the country so what was the
next step then well of course that would
be ruling the entire country in 2014
Modi became India's Prime Minister
[Music]
his program included ending a lot of
bureaucracy modernizing country and
improving the country's relationship
with America don't forget that India
used to be blacklisted by the White
House because of their nuclear program
so Modi actually did a great job of
getting close to Washington yeah you
heard that right he went from not having
a visa to entering the states and
becoming Obama's personal friends don't
believe me well just check this out
Obama writes profile for Modi in times
most influential list yes you heard that
right Barack Obama himself became
besties with Modi despite them having
opposing ideologies he might wonder
house is even possible basically
everybody was expecting India's economy
to boom just like China's hat and Modi
seemed like the man for the drop Ri Ri
so he might not be the biggest human
rights fan but this is international
politics and we've seen worse but now
the question is did Modi really pull
India out of poverty what has he done
during his time in office let's have a
look shall we
[Music]
[Applause]
the Hindu Trump imagine if I said
Gandhi's assassin was a patriot you
might think that this isn't the best
thing to say during an electoral
campaign in India but this is what
Prager Thakur said before the elections
progress occur is a politician from the
BJP and yes she has won the elections in
her districts just like Modi did and if
this isn't brutal enough for you just
look at this quote from a Machado
chairman of the party lammott Shah vows
to throw illegal immigrants into the Bay
of Bengal I did tell you at the end of
this video you'll think that Donald
Trump was a Hollywood liberal and just
wait because you haven't seen anything
yet now you might be wondering how is it
possible that with such a radical agenda
Modi and his party had a landslide
victory well the answer lies in one word
economics in this regard Modi reminds us
of Aragon the Turkish president both are
religious extremists both had good
relationships with Americans both
bragged about economics some points wait
a minute did you say that you don't know
anything about Erdogan good news we
talked about him in another video I'm
going to link to that and don't forget
that if you want to discover what
happens around the world you should
absolutely subscribe to visual politic
and hit that Bell button so you won't
miss out on any posts and hitting that
Bell button is really important because
it'll allow you to get a notification on
your mobile phone anytime we publish a
new video which is nice and we do that
several times a week so don't miss those
hit that Bell but let's get back to our
story under Modi's government the Indian
economy kept growing at a 7% rate his
administration managed to balance the
accounts by creating new taxes like v8e
and this man has crafted himself an
image of a humble hard-working and
business friendly politician but as we
said before the radical influences then
present during his entire administration
basically he's given the sharing family
the keys to the government today the
group controls the police they are me
and the courts that's not all they
control the biggest private school in
the country this means that five million
children are educated every day
alongside their extremist principals and
if the Shang family isn't radical enough
for you there are other organizations
that make headlines like this one
mahjong doll activists beat up Muslim
boy for going shopping with Hindu girl
as you can see the advance of Hindu
radicalism is becoming more and more
worrying and I say Hindu radicalism
because Modi's core ideology goes way
beyond simple nationalism for example
his government has offered Indian
nationality to a lot of immigrants from
Bangladesh Afghanistan or even Pakistan
they just have to meet one condition
not being Muslim so yes Vijay peas
radicalism is a religious one they want
India to just have Hinduism Buddhism or
other small local religions and you
might wonder so well what's wrong with
that it's their country and those aren't
their religions right well in that case
do you remember that India still has
more than 200 million Muslims they
represent 14% of the entire population
and believe me their lives are not easy
why well let's get back to those sacred
cows shall we
before Modi became Prime Minister cows
were sacred until the moments they
weren't productive anymore then
authorities let them get slaughtered so
their meat could be eaten usually those
slaughterhouses were owned by Muslims
and Muslims were the ones who ate the
beef - under the BJP rule many states
have banned beef consumption and the
government has spent almost ninety
million dollars building cow shelters
known as cash Arliss inside of these
shelters cows are protected under Hindu
religious principles and they promote
vegetarianism of course all these
measures are a direct attack on the
Muslim community many Muslim families
lived off the production of cow meat and
now they've lost their livelihoods but
most of the radical groups this is just
not enough
so in today's India it's easy to find
news like this
Kal Virgil ante is in India killed at
least 44 people report finds about 280
people injured in more than a hundred
tacks over three years as all of you
before you can find fanatics in any
religion all right so you might be
wondering now what about the economics
can we really say Modi was successful in
this regard the truth is also pretty
disappointing so let's have a look
[Music]
smoke streams January the 30th is the
school day of non-violence and peace and
observance of the day Gandhi was
assassinated at this moment in the video
you already know that Gandhi and Modi
couldn't be more different if Gandhi was
a Peace icon Modi is a social pyromaniac
while it's true that India is still
growing
we shouldn't give credit to Modi for
this in fact India started growing
decades ago and its population is
growing too
[Music]
what isn't growing is the job market
specifically employment for youths young
unemployment is at a record high and
Modi's promised to create 10 million
jobs is still just a promise also
farmers are angry Modi increased food
imports to make prices cheaper this is
great for the cities but it's not great
for the countryside even if this
liberalisation was good in the long term
it made moody lose a lot of votes in
rural areas and the same goes for his
fight against the shadow economy this is
perhaps his biggest failure overnight
government retired 80% of Indian
currency from circulation they wanted to
force everyone to use credit cards and
bank transfers instead of cash this way
they couldn't evade taxes
the problem not everyone has a bank
account in India and financial
institutions they were not well prepared
for this so all of a sudden you had
hundreds of people go into the bank
officers trying to open an account and
the bankers didn't even know what to do
and who suffered the most well of course
it was the poorest people those who had
small businesses like a hassle on a
street fruit shop or other small
business had lots of trouble making ends
meet
all of this explains why at the
beginning of 2019 polls looked really
bad for Modi of course he would still
win the elections but he would lose the
absolute majority and he would have to
form coalition's with other parties so
what does an extremist politician do
when he wants to rise in the polls well
the same thing and again did the same
old protectionism India curbs power of
Amazon and Walmart to sell products
online but as we said before Modi as a
total pyromaniac and team knows how to
create smoke screens this is why in
order to raise national pride tensions
with Pakistan their diehard enemy other
a great thing under Modi India performed
their first airstrike against Pakistan
territory in 40 years
this was their response to the Kashmir
terrorist attack fortunately this
conflict hasn't become a nuclear war but
it has been a great help for Modi in the
elections as we said in 2019 polls said
Modi wouldn't have the absolute majority
now six months after that Modi has had a
huge victory remember the figure that
party has 65 percent of seats in
parliament
and now the question goes to you do you
think Modi is playing with fire using
this ultra-nationalist strategy can Modi
get India out of poverty is Gandhi's
legacy lost in this country well please
leave your answer in the comment section
below
also don't forget to check out our
friends from the reconsider Media
podcast the podcast that provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine and remember that we publish brand
new videos every week so please do
subscribe to this channel and hit that
Bell button so you won't miss any posts
if you like this video give us a thumbs
up and as always I'll see you next time
if you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and here's some more
of my lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider at
WWE consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast